こんにちははじめしゃちょーです
皆さんリュックサックリュックって使って
ますでしょうかよく移動する時に荷物
たくさんあると思ってリュックとかバック
使うと思うんですけれどもあ
俺がよく使ってるのはまこういう普通の
サイズのバッグなんですけどもまみんな
こういう感じの使うと思うんですよ
リュックとかバッグで
[音楽]
あのー
そんないらんやろとそんなにいらんやろっ
ていうくらいあのほんと僕も見たことない
くらい暫定ですけども
世界一大きいリュックが売ってました
わかんない世の中にはまだまだ大きな
リュックが存在するかもしれませんが気軽
に買えるもう皆さんも買います
スタイリング買っておきます
案件じゃないです
案件じゃないけどねちょっとリンクもあっ
て誰でもそうに変えるって言うだけ伝えて
おく誰でもすぐ買えるリュックの中で
間違いなく世界一でかい超巨大なリュック
見つけたのでやばいんですよサイトの画像
がちょっとご覧くださいこちらどうぞ
どうこれこんな大きいことある意味わかん
ないくらい大きくてもう画像見た瞬間が僕
疑ったんですよえこんなの存在するの
かって
存在しました持ってこいと思います
はいそんなに段ボールは大きくないけど
ちょっとだけ開けたら間違いなくこれでし
たねじゃあ行きますね
[音楽]
ほらもうほら見てこのリュックあるある
なんでさリュックにはさあこのいつも
コンセントがついてるんでしょうね見て
わかるときコンセントの大きさもかなり
でかいんですよこれは何なんキーホルダー
とかストラップつける部分なんですねこれ
付いてるリュックありがちよね何が全然
違うよとあると思うんですけどちょっと
ダンボールから出してみましょう
間違いなく
圧縮されて
密封されてるからこういう状態なんです
けどもちょっと開けます
ねこれメイドインジャパンでございます
日本でございますこれ作ったの
はいもうこれで結構やばいなと思うんです
けどよしじゃあちょっと広げてみますいき
ますよ
はいちょっと
待ってよ
でっかぁ皆さんこれですこんなリュック見
たことあるちょっと実際に数えてみます
ちなみに僕身長186cmあって結構
大きいんですけども
俺が担いでももう
デカすぎやろ
でかすぎやろこれはちょっとどうなって
ますどうなってますパラシュートで今から
パラシュートで
降りるのか
いや
すげーめっちゃくちゃでかいですよこれ
いいやめっちゃくちゃでかいぞどれぐらい
入るんでしょう
開けてみます
[音楽]
やばいなんか小さいポケットとかはないん
ですけどももう大口のマジで何でも入るん
じゃないかぐらい超大きいですねこれ俺
入れるんじゃねこれ人入れたらもうすごい
よね
行けそういけそうな感じはあるこれ多分
いけるわこれいけるいけるこれですごい人
連れて歩きますなんか昔同じようなことし
た記憶があるな
ただ今回はすごいですよリュックですから
ね
進められるぞすごいすごい
閉まりました
みんなどう
俺リアクションになった
さっきやばい
待ってやばいよ
待って
暗い
めっちゃ汗かいた今一瞬で
嫌なこと思い出しちゃった
なーい人
入れますこのリュック
入りそうだってさ俺が入りたってことは
大抵のオーナーも入れられるっていう認識
で大丈夫なはずおーすごい
顔ごといけるぞ
えすごい
皆さん全然問題なく入りましたここも一応
入りますね
ノートパソコン8台は入りますうさぎさん
入れようと思いますすごいないやすごい
マジでどうでしょう
すっかり片付けてますでしょうかでも
やっぱでかいなおい相当でかいけどいや
これマジで
史上最強に物語のリュックですわ
トランセルも入るないやすごいなこれ
すごいのがさちゃんと見た目がリュックな
のすごいっすよね前から見ても普通のなん
か感覚おかしくなりそうだな普通の人間と
並んだらこうですからねでかいよかなり
また入るの怖いんですけど
これだったらの中に俺がいても後輩気づか
ない説あるなちょっと入ってみます
後輩に飲みました
またこの中もうやだバイバイさらば
[音楽]
何
あっそこにいたやばいいやちょっとやばい
やばい
死んじゃうマジでやばいよって
背負ってはいこれリュックだからなるほど
ぴよって
背負って
助けてごめん
助けてあげて
いやー
汗やば
普通に
命を感じだね
ゴーンカルロス
これ
怖いですねどうちょっと
乾燥してて感想
いや暗くて怖いっていうのと
意外と
俺はステーチってんで丈夫です丈夫じゃ
ないわ
広いです
ちょっと
あーこれやったわ
初めてだー
そろそろ
これ
[音楽]